quatre jours pour séduire et trois
entreprises yvelinoise le consumer
electronics show et le rendez vous
international des nouvelles technologies
lamberth renora a fait le voyage pour
faire connaître son gyropode mois-ci
rencontrer du monde et rencontrer les
bonnes personnes c'est-à-dire un que
nous on cherche plutôt des premiers
clients des distributeurs
parce que si on va attaquer par exemple
le marché américain et puis pourquoi pas
les investisseurs qui seraient
intéressés au projet qui voudraient
rentrer etc
c'est un peu un peu large nous on est
dans une phase où on peut se permettre
de chercher un peu de tout autre
start-up la société bélizienne oled
comme son produit là les filles une
alternative au wifi qui transmet des
données par la lumière
on a produit industrialisés est prêt à
être commandés et livrés en juillet de
cette année il peut espérer la fin du
texte a sur sa position de leader sur
les marchés technologiques
on a eu une visite d'à peu près une
centaine de personnes très vite les gens
sont en général renseigner sur la
technologie c'est vraiment des gentils
qui sont soit très intéressé par la
technologie ou des aux entreprises
françaises
une grosse présence de la france dans
les technologies une troisième
innovation yvelinoise est présente à las
vegas un chargeur sans fil pensé par
energy square 170 mille visiteurs sont
attendus pour ce crs il fermera ses
portes le 12 janvier